welcome to pymol 101 with molecular
memory
KP here and today we'll be learning all
about the different ways to measure the
distance between atoms and primal
examining distances between atoms is
important because it can tell us if a
potential molecular interaction does or
doesn't exist
today's structure is 1a00
let's load it as usual and display the
sequence
this is actually segments of two
interacting proteins from bacteria
so let's learn a new pie mole preset
that models the interaction of two
proteins
action preset protein interface nice
chain a the green chain is part of a
protein that can cause a change in the
movement of bacterial flagella
and the cyan chain B is a segment of a
protein that activates the green chain
this protein Duo helps bacteria move in
response to chemical signals in their
environment
proteins form when many amino acids
undergo dehydration reactions to link up
together
these reactions are between an amine and
a carboxylic acid
but because proteins are chains one end
will have an amine that didn't react and
the other will have a carboxylic acid
that didn't react
the amine end is called the n-terminus
and the end with the unreacted
carboxylic acid is the c-terminus
it's easy to identify these in primal
by convention the n-terminus is listed
as the first amino acid in the chain and
the c-terminus is last let's select
these rename them Termini
and then Zoom now show the Termini as
sticks
s sticks here's the amine of the
n-terminus and here's the carboxylic
acid group of the c-terminus notice in
the sequence chain B has a bunch of
grayed out amino acids that can't be
seen in the structure below
sometimes a crystallographer will list
them because they were present in the
protein that was crystallized but didn't
show up well enough in the crystal
structure to give 3D coordinates for
let's Zoom back out and then manually
zoom in on the interface with the
trackpad or Mouse
notice amino acids near the interacting
region are automatically shown as sticks
with this preset convenient let's see if
there's some polar contacts ionic
interactions and or hydrogen bonds a
find
polar contacts between chains and there
they are the group of polar contacts
shows up in the names panel
if we find the measurements distracting
we can hide the labels and just show the
lines
now polar contacts aren't the only
stabilizing interactions at protein
interfaces or in binding sites
Van Der waals interactions like induced
dipoles contribute as well
and nonpolar chains cluster together in
the hydrophobic effect
to see if these interactions are present
we have to manually measure
using the drop down wizard menu choose
measurement now we'll manually measure
between two nonpolar side chains ones
that only contain carbon atoms the
measurement wizard pops up just above
the mouse control menu
and this prompt in the upper left of the
structure viewer directs us to click on
the first atom
let's look for some nonpolar
interactions here's a valine side chain
that looks pretty close to this
isoleucine
as long as the measurement is about 4.4
angstroms or less it's likely these
surfaces are interacting
let's pick the carbon on the valine that
appears to be closest to the isoleucine
now we'll measure to this Carbon on
isoleucine
4.2 that's a likely interaction
let's see if there are any others
oh this phenylalanine is pretty close to
this tyrosine
check this out tyrosine has a polar
contact a hydrogen bond to glutamate
right here
because of the oxygen it can make polar
interactions
but it's got a big carbon ring too let's
measure between these two rings and yep
3.9 likely some hydrophobic clustering
going on there a quick way to identify
whether an amino acid side chain can
make polar contacts is to look for blue
or red in the chain
nitrogen and oxygen are polar atoms and
can make polar contacts but any side
chain with a lot of carbon atoms can
make favorable Van Der waals
interactions too
the tyrosine side chain we looked at is
a great example of a side chain that can
participate in both types of
interactions I'll finish this lesson
with a quick word of caution
sometimes the more granular fine polar
contacts commands don't work as expected
I suspect it's the way information is
coded in some pdb files but if you don't
see any contacts When selecting
something like just intramine chain
double check that by selecting polar
contacts to any atoms
and that's a wrap on this lesson join me
next time when we take a deep dive into
secondary structure and learn more about
the measurement wizard settings